all right listen podcasts are taking
over why are they taking over i'm gonna
ask my guests in a minute my humble
opinion is
man social media is just a place for
fighting and bickering and
just bots and stupidity uh
in the overwhelming majority of the
noise but when you want to have a long
considered conversation like we're
having now
podcasts are such a reprieve from the
the inanes of uh
social media and the lack of depth and
we kind of get back to expertise and boy
do we have expertise
today dan granger runs oxford road which
is one of
i don't know what are you one of the top
three agencies in podcasting i mean you
kind of pioneered this all
yeah i think that's fair thank you yeah
uh
and you started working with all those
d2c direct consumer companies but now
it's expanding
um i'm curious what you think of clips
and
what you think of sort of micro content
and this
growing trend where people are clipping
up the podcasts and
and people may be consuming little
pieces of it
right well first of all as a promotional
tool
you know samples are always the best if
you can do it and when you're in
entertainment of any kind of product you
want to show a trailer you want to give
people a taste of what they're going to
get if they come for the whole thing
right so i think as a promotional
vehicle all day long
everywhere you can get it where there's
a like audience that might have an
interest in that
i think you're touching on something
that's very important when we talk about
what the next
revolution is going to be um in the
space because thing has to keep evolving
and and i am predicting that i think
um multi-length content is going to be a
big deal wait to find what multi-length
content is
basically not every show has to be an
hour long oh why
not yeah yeah the show ends when it's
not interesting which is how howard
stern started doing it
joe rogue and i do it everybody right
but but at the same time you know if you
i don't know how far you've gone with
alexa and flash briefings but i think
there's a very interesting model that's
starting to occur where you can actually
string together
little samples of your favorite news
outlets and get them in byte sizes and
through voice command tell them what you
want next put them in any order that you
want and it's in constant rotation
and being refreshed all the time now
that hasn't really connected yet with
the personality driven
ecosystem that is podcast right now it's
very focused on news
but i think that's going to change i'm
calling that right now i think that's
going to be a big big deal because
look i may want to hear everything that
you have to say this week and yet i've
only got 10 minutes for you
can i get a best of can i get it curated
so that i can have some of so i can have
the highlights or i can pick and choose
more
i i yeah i think the best of in the
clips is kind of
interesting the thing i don't like which
i'm seeing more of marco
is people taking my show and other shows
clipping them and then inserting
advertising in between them
and i i think stitcher did this to me at
some point i went
bonkers on the stitcher people i was
like guys
uh what are you doing like you you put
your because they were selling ads in
front of the podcast
and you didn't get a taste and i didn't
get my beak wet and i'm like
hey guys you're and the reason i found
out about it because one of their sales
people
i think i'm listening if it wasn't
stitch i'm sorry but it was one of them
and i and i i turned out i knew somebody
who was running and i said
if you're gonna if you're gonna have
your sales people saying they're selling
ads before my podcast or in between my
podcast and this week in tech
or whatever it is like i'm i'm going to
block you from using our feed and i'm
going to send you a legal letter and
they back down and they said well what
would it take i said don't do it
i don't want your ads anywhere near i
don't want you selling it i don't want
30 percent of what you sell and i want
100 of what you sell
i don't want you selling against my ads
what are your thoughts on on this sort
of growing trend
well the good thing is that that has
mostly not happened recently like that
that i think you're right that was
stitcher back in the day and they
they did stop doing it eventually
because it caused so much blowback um
but
the good thing is i got it right it was
stitcher right good yeah i'm pretty sure
that's right um the good thing is that
uh now you are in full control for the
most part
that platforms like spotify i'm pretty
sure either
already has announced plans to do that
or at least you when you when you sign
up for spotify to have your podcast
playable in spotify
uh you agree to let them do things like
that um
and that's why like you know apps like
overcast i don't have to ask everybody
to play their podcasts i don't have to
have you opt in and agree to my terms
i'm just reading your rss feed and
playing what's there and if i don't like
if i don't
inject my own ads in the middle of your
show that
nobody has any problem with that because
that's fine right i'm just playing the
rss feed that's there
um but if you have a platform that's
going to start doing that to your
content that's going to
really like modify it like that uh then
they have to get your permission by by
most interpretations of
of the copyright issues here so the good
thing is that those platforms
if they if they still just at all tend
to be opt in the bad thing
is that if spotify gets so much market
share that you pretty much have to opt
in to have your stuff yeah
reach a big audience then you basically
lose control of yourself and this is
this is the youtube problem right like
if you want to have video out there in
the world that anybody sees
you pretty much have to agree to
whatever youtube dictates right
and so again like this is why i i try
very hard to not let this happen in the
podcast space
if any app gets like significant market
share
and they start dictating terms we're all
going to have to agree to them
and that's not a good place to be for
creators or listeners frankly
and so that's why it's so important to
keep this ecosystem as open as possible
and to
to actively fight against you know
entities like spotify that are that are
that are going the other direction